almost all people said that criminal
justice reform would never pass but we
came together as a group we worked
across party lines and we got it done
I'm truly humbled I'm grateful I'm
thankful Jared president thanked that
you were insisting about getting this
bill passed it's an experience that I
know forget two months ago I was in a
prison cell and I'm in the White House
that's that's continued to make America
great again wow that celebration just
hours ago at the White House for the
first step back the bipartisan criminal
justice reform just passed by Congress
in December it was a personal mission
for my next guest today I sat down
exclusively with the president's
son-in-law senior advisor Jared Kushner
to talk about that law his reaction to
the Muller report new questions about
his security clearance and a lot more
Jared it's great to have you with us
thanks for joining us you're gonna do a
lot of interviews so we're really happy
about that it's my pleasure to be here
oh so you have a big event that we're
gonna get to the first step back to big
celebration a bipartisan celebration in
the White House which is great because I
don't think we have enough of those
we're gonna get to that because it's a
historic day in many ways but we have to
get some of the news of the day first
and the left is going crazy about the
security clearance issue and a
whistleblower from the White House is
now given a private interview on Capitol
Hill Democrats and she says that 25
individuals were able to leapfrog over
the the career people's concerns about
security clearances and they received
security clearances in her view
improperly what's your reaction to that
now well I can't comment for the White
House's process but what I can say is
that over the last two years that I've
been here I've been accused of all
different types of things and all of
those things that turned out to be false
we've had a lot of crazy accusations
like that we colluded with Russia I
complied with all the different
investigations whether it be the Senate
the house the special counsel I've sat
for nearly 20 hours of interviews with
them when I came to Washington I had a
very successful business career I had
extensive holdings I disclosed all my
holdings to the
office of government ethics and what I
did with that is they taught me what to
divest what to keep what rules to follow
she says they were grave concern she has
grave concerns about potential national
security implications do you pose a
grave national security concern to the
country very kosher look I can say that
in the White House I work with some
phenomenal people and I think over the
last two years the president's done a
phenomenal job of identifying what are
our national security priorities he's
had a great team in place that are
helping implement it and I hope I've
played a good part in pushing those
objectives forward and I think because
of the president's leadership the world
is safer today I so the sense of the
Democrats keep moving the goal posts on
this I mean it strikes me as interesting
that this comes out today after Muller
fizzles yeah well what I learned during
the campaign is that there's a big
difference between what people in
America care about and what people in
Washington or in the media care about
when you think about the first step back
I was reading back on what seeing them
was saying about it after it passed it
was like they couldn't believe that
Donald Trump would do something that
would help disadvantaged people people
who've made this big mistake some of
them criminal mistakes and they'd it's
almost like they didn't want to believe
it could ever happen does that does that
disappoint you because even when
something that should be bipartisan is
still viewed in a negative light odd
when he was approached with this issue
and he saw how a lot of people leaving
prison didn't have the skillset and
didn't have had so many obstacles
preventing them from getting back on a
path he said of course that's why
they'll go back and commit more crimes
so he thought it was good for Public
Safety and also for these people to
figure out how do we invest the
resources to help them have a better
chance at succeeding and that's
something he did because he does I think
a very competent executive but it's also
something he did because he has a big
heart how much of it was because of your
dad and what your dad went to prison he
was convicted he served time what does
he say about these kinds of issues with
you well that was a big part I mean that
was
I was exposed to the issue and had I
just come in as a government employee
with you know hearing from the top down
about what a great job they were doing I
probably would have believed it but
there's so much more that we can be
doing and my experience in prison with
my family situation was I met a lot of
different families a lot of people who a
lot of more good people they just made a
mistake and the toll that that had paid
on that that had weighed on them and on
their families was very disproportionate
where is the president's thinking on the
border closing he sent out a lot of
interesting tweets about closing the
border where is he on that well I think
the president's definitely made
increased awareness to the issue I think
he's weighing all of his options which
is something the president was this all
for to pressure Mexico no I think it's
the pressure everybody this is something
that needs a solution one of the things
I love about the president is he doesn't
let people hide from problems you know
when there's a problem he makes people
confront the problem and he's very
creative about ways that he'll look to
find that to find a solution you're
gonna get the USMC a pastor of Congress
so I think it's moving very steadily to
craft the deal obviously I have to give
a lot of credit to the president for
creating the conditions for us to
negotiate the deal but I have to give a
lot of credit to ambassador Light Heiser
who really did a brilliant job not only
in negotiating the deal but also in
terms of architecting what kind of deal
he thought would appeal to all the
different constituents and what we're
seeing now with the deal is that it's
something that really is a world-class
trade agreement it's great for our
farmers great for American worker is
great for industry great for technology
and it's all these things that will
allow American content to be independent
I don't think still trashing this deal I
mean need David Nora I think it was on I
think we have the soundbite on MSNBC is
an anchor reporter there this is what he
just said like last couple of days about
the u.s. embassy a let's watch talking
about the president's seeming inability
to see humanity he is very easily able
to see the economics of stories like
this one and you look at what's happened
with the US Mexico Canada trade deal the
new NAFTA it's fallen apart used the
president's Twitter feed as a guide here
that may very well be what spurred the
President to make this threat he was
talking about closing the border there
he but he brought up too close the
border issue because the US MCA is quote
falling apart
any truth to that no not at all the the
feature that I love that people don't
talk about is that we built in a 16 year
sunset which I was always I always
thought about the fact that if you've
got a great asset you don't want to sell
the asset we could always sell our
market access what we do here is we
really lease our market access and then
we do is every six years we have a fair
market value renewal so that we can
rebalance you were instrumental in the
president's run in 2016 what are you
seeing in this Democrat field any any
interesting characters more some more
than others that you'd like to run
against we looked at 2020 what we're
focused on is figuring out how do we you
know keep building the the best way
possible the president's gonna have a
fabulous campaign I think he's got the
right policies and I think he's got the
country on the right track and I think
that a lot of the different policies
that I see a lot of these Democrats
advocating for or offering I don't think
that's where the countries are I don't
think that's where the country is one
statistic that I found very pleasing is
that more of the the in Florida they
passed a law where former felons can now
vote we've had more expel ins registered
registers Republicans and Democrats and
I think they see the reforms we've had
more felons ex felons register as
Republicans and Democrats that that's
the data that I've seen I think that
will surprise a lot of people when they
see the new coalition that President
Trump is building for what the
Republican Party has the potential to be